c'est un beau projet en fait qui est qui
est arrivé est tout à fait par hasard
mais en même temps qui répond vraiment
besoin parce que publier qu' on est en
avril puis un autre qui fâchent au même
des aliments à la chaleur c'est parce
que le plus sécuritaire pour la santé
non donc de donner accès à des camions
réfrigérés pendant tout la période de
l'été va être extrêmement important pour
les organismes et intelligent finalement
qu'ils vont recevoir leur repas dans les
meilleures conditions avec des leds ou
là de la collaboration des sautes député
de la région de montréal parce que
évidemment vous parlez des 45 et
organismes et sont tous distribués aux
dans le territoire montréalais il ya
plusieurs députés ces circonscriptions
l'a donc avec la collaboration d'autres
partis d'autres députés dans ce projet
en fait pour le moment je vous dirais
que nous on a parti on est parti d'une
initiative de quartier 1 comme en inde
et organise de notre quartier puis
finalement en faisant un sondage pour
factions en réalisé un sondage pour
savoir s'ils avaient des besoins quels
étaient les besoins
ce sondage a en fait a été partagé
beaucoup et finalement se retrouver avec
tous les arrondissements de montréal et
même en partie une particularité de
longueur qui en avaient besoin
donc c'est au départ c'était parti d'un
besoin local et aujourd'hui c'est rendu
un besoin primaire ne l'avait pas prévu
comme ça donc moi je vous dirais gély
vraiment laisser tout l'espace à bord
faction à katyn pour toutes de décider
comment il voulait développer ce projet
là moi je suis vraiment soutien puis je
les accompagne dans les diverses
demandes de financement qui auront à
faire pour s'assurer qu'on va finaliser
le financement
vous savez ça l'air de rien mais achetez
un camion réfrigéré
un camion de 10 12 pieds par exemple
c'est pas loin de 50 milles à 60 mo de
ram donc c'est sûr que un organisme
jamais avoir un camion réfrigéré à us et
des coûts énormes la location de 9 à 10
camions à peu près là on parle d'un coût
de 50 milles par mois mais qui va offrir
dix camions réfrigérés partout sur le
territoire
donc c'est sûr que le financement
élevé mais les importants parce que dans
la période de confinement pendant la
période où on veut respecter les
directives de la santé publique pour non
seulement que les aliments sont bien
distribués mais il faut que les
chauffeurs soient protégés pour que les
gens qui fassent distribution soit
protégé donc tout un système a développé
pour ce qui est de travailler avec les
autres députés
moi je vous dirais que tous les bureaux
de députés élus ont été informés de ce
projet là parce que je pense que ça peut
bénéficier tout le monde donc c'est
quelque chose que bouffe action vaut
faire mais comme je vous disais au
départ on est parti d'un projet qui
était très locale puisqu'elle a par le
succès en fait de deux ça parce qu'il
répond en fait à me demande c'est allé
beaucoup plus loin que juste notre notre
territoire de compter mais nous on est
très ouverts à tous les députés de la
remarque et puis validé à ce que ce
projet de son succès parce que je pense
qu'il répond vraiment à un besoin
une dernière question parce que je sais
que vous savez d'autres choses à faire
aujourd'hui le nom des choses dont je
suis une dernière question dans votre
circonscription quels sont les les
besoins les plus criants dans le cadre
de cette pandémie parce qu'on parle de
l'alimentation qui était une
préoccupation de beaucoup de députés de
beaucoup de ministres si on a parlé à la
ministre gould la semaine dernière que
même au niveau international c'est une
grande préoccupation pour le canada mais
audelà de la sécurité alimentaire y at
il d'autres préoccupations importantes
dans votre circonscription qui vous
voyez vous qui vous partagez avec vos
collègues
moi je pense que c'est sûr que ce qu'on
vit actuellement dans cette crise sans
précédent nous touche tous bien sûr avec
certaines différences construire une
métropole urbaine ou un une ville qui
est plus en région où les enjeux
notamment d'agriculture on est important
donc de ce qui s'en vient au niveau 2 de
pouvoir assurer la chaîne
d'approvisionnement en alimentant vient
donc les défis peuvent être des fois un
peu varié mais moi je pense que à la
base le défi qu'on a comme gouvernement
est le défi que les gens vivent dans ma
circonscription et je pense partout au
pays
c'est la grande anxiété qui est non
seulement une entité financière mais
aussi une anxiété sanitaire de santé
donc comment on passe à travers puis
commença sûr que les gens qu'on aime qui
nos amis notre famille sont en santé
puis s'ils attrapent le virus b qui
survivra ce virus donc c'est une
combinaison d'anxiétés extrêmement
grande que moi je pense qu'actuellement
dans mon comté ce qu'on vit beaucoup
c'est les petites artères commerciales
qui finalement se promènent qui on rend
compte qu'il ya quel point sont
silencieuses et ça ça fait peur les gens
perdent eux pour retrouver finalement
cette vitalité locale qui compte qu'on
adore choquer les gens les familles qui
se retrouvent avec un du jour au
lendemain parce que cette crise est
arrivée comme un vrai tsunami les gens
n'ont pour venir se retrouve pour la
première fois de leur vie a demandé des
paniers alimentaires ce qu'il n'avait
jamais fait
donc il est tout aussi une préoccupation
de comment je passe au travers
comment je m'assurer que mes enfants
sont nourris que j'ai un toit sur la
tête que j'ai un frigo que de la
nourriture dedans
donc ça c'est c'est je pense oui c'est
si dans ma circonscription mais c'est
partout au pays
c'est pas juste là au soleil à martin
espère à la députée fédérale de la
circonscription d'hochelaga merci
d'avoir accepté cette entrevue pour
radio canada international
merci de m'avoir invité à votre émission